la harley davidson bien plus qu'un
loisir une passion pour les bikers
évident acheter les armes et ça va
la harley davidson cette moto
originaires des etats unis sillonne les
routes depuis le début du 20e siècle
être biker c'est une façon de vivre
c'est la bécane c'est la musique c'est
le cuir ça c'est l'attirail du parfait
biker sans oublier les tatouages les
bijoux et une conduite reconnaissable de
loin bref être un vrai biker ou une
vraie bikeuse c'est avoir un style bien
particulier
harley davidson les t-shirts les boucles
de ceinturon les casquettes les
portefeuilles etc ils sont nombreux à
être mordus de cette bécane parmi eux le
chanteur christophe casque blanc sur la
tête à 55 kg fait je crois pas loin de
500 kg de fort
bon christophe lanne mais conduire cette
moto c'est aussi pour la frime ce qui me
plaît c'est quand je vois une harley je
regarde si elle mais pâtit lme frime moi
ce qui me plaît c'est de me faire free
mais parler aussi c'est pas simplement
de frimer donc on frime c'est qu'on
existe
et il aime sa frime et les bikers
surtout quand ils se rassemblent en
communauté
quelques noms de clubs d'arts les voici
les ocz est requise de strasbourg a fait
douze ans je roule en moto au but quoi
les thunderbirds de lorraine ont lem
comme une femme et les sexistes vont
dire que c'est encore le prolongement de
notre sexe ou encore les langues d'oc
riders près de montpellier que j'aime
c'est le plaisir de rouler en bande sans
faire les fous parce que nous ne voulons
pas très vite
tous ces passionnés de grosses
cylindrées devrait se donner rendez vous
sur internet ce mercredi la marque
harley-davidson va dévoiler une nouvelle
gamme de motos dont des éditions
limitées un événement virtuel attendu
par les bikers du monde entier
[Musique]